pour le moment ils sont avec nous et on
va accueillir tout de suite mercedes et
jeanine
[Applaudissements]
tu as posé
bonsoir les sommes extrêmement bien m'en
vraiment chère mais elle est mignonne
celle-là par email ou dallas le guide au
dessus la russie j'aurais po lu maxime
galy bakana castaldi malaisie attention
ici et maxime ni ce soir vous serez aux
platines encore on adore ça a tellement
bien marché vendredi qu'il sera aux
platines ce soir vous mettrez à midi qui
en plus avaient des scoops des scoops
des médias et les informations
complémentaires avait exactement
puisqu'il reviendra à touba avec les cd
ou kelly elle est en train de tourner le
film les dégâts actuellement dans les
alentours de martigues marseille à deux
attention va que maintenant valérie
bénaïm boulot
[Applaudissements]
me qualifier là-bas dans des soies celle
de la mère d'iris churchill à poupet sur
la vie de ma mère benhaim alferov gars
c'est la salle poupée qui tâte à kaboul
avec des boulettes
il est acquis mais c'est un vrai chien
mérite un vrai chez sa fille ces jo à
peu près mais il te mens au caire mais
s'appelle elle s'appelle et marc et moi
être aimable mais vous êtes trop bien à
qui elle est à deux jeunes filles qui
m'ont prêté gentiment à l'appréhension
l'a peut-être cac est en train de
chercher son chien actuellement donc
voilà il est là et marie la laiterie
mignonne et les années merci et trélody
alors allez-y betty bull en tout cas
personnel et là on a on a la classe vous
avez que franck dubosc a joué dans
bienvenue à bord et bien christine kelly
est là elle est hôtesse d'accueil dans
un paquebot a regardé tout simplement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui fait du merci d'être avec
nous c'est que les gens adorent ça y est
ça y est ça fait déjà ton entrée dans
l'émission est ce que vous l'avez
accepté dans la famille christine kelly
merci merci à vous ma christine mes
toiles à bachir et on a maintenant à
dahouët on à julie etc et dinard des
petites annonces d'elie regardez c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
j'ai 16 ans c'est très triste mais moi
je m'appelle julie je suis depuis trois
jours avec justin
si tout va bien il me mène à la fois pas
votre micro avec des cachets ma part on
ne plaint poitrine
est ce que vous avez à microbes à
banaliser de cacher vous êtes très belle
comme ça merci isabelle morini-bosc du
gard dès les séries
franck a également joué dans disco
bernard montiel est là
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est pas la relève de l'amour ça j'ai
jamais vu un mec danser aussi mal même
faire ça il a il le fait sans risquer
quoi je me suis entraîné en plus apte à
regarder van hinte y avait ça il fallait
que ça arrive et j'y suis né bernet
avoir moins le rythme que bernard
montiel c'était une musique n'importe
quoi ils dansent une musique vous allez
voir
est ce que vous trouvez sexe continue
dans ce non non non non non c'est vrai
que vous augmentez mignon des travolta
merci et christine vous trouvez sexe pas
quand il danse allez on a tout eu dire
des mots anglais les plus grands buteurs
du cinéma français ni rodrigues
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça m'attriste de bruitages depuis plus
de 150 ans et nous pouvons venir chez
vous pour faire des bruitages de style
touche pas à mon poste
bonjour mes petites nouveautés oh là là
quelle d'arcade en france passer la fête
ont tué nos bons en mauricie j'aime
beaucoup votre petit million et jean-luc
toujours la paire upped waberi me va
tout me va c'est ça qui c'est un
avantage
allez on va accueillir maintenant bien
sûr un des rôles les plus célèbres de
franck dubosc
à votre avis qui pouvait faire patrick
chirac abba banani qu'un unique jean
michel meyer bien entendu patrick
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on attend pas patrick alors
comment vous le trouvez ça passait la
série bat simon bold mcdoom et là des
belles jambes on avait ça me faisait
débat limoges en innu déjà ci ne pas
manger des trucs à vous être très drôle
merci vous sortez de là comme ça
monsieur aubin il fait je suis frais
jean-michel comprend
[Applaudissements]